the right moment oh okay dude
just repeating the position once ding
would love a drawer right now
he's been losing for most of the game uh
but dude can he stop the white rook
infiltrating maybe the black king can
hide at the side of the board
he's repeating the position and he takes
the draw duda he repeats what in a
winning position
the tension got too much it was not easy
we must say the final position he was
more winning earlier on he missed some
chances but
dude has got to be disappointed he was
winning at least two games today that we
saw
he let it slip though ding lives to
fight another day oh wow
four draws in the quarter final first
match between
dingley ran and young christophe duda
and
i'm curious i mean okay look at ding
looking he's smiling he's
is he unhappy with his play but happy
with the result here i think both
players are equally
confused and unhappy at the same time i
mean such sharp chess from both of them
it was just
we couldn't ignore the computers it was
just action everywhere and both sides
trying to win throwing at everything at
each other
should duda have kept playing here do
you think would he have had chances yes
but there was some risk
that's why i think he just wants to get
rid of all the risk and just make it a
one day shootout tomorrow